the director of the refugee support
network Catherine Gladwell is here and
Catherine I know you do an awful lot of
work your charity does an awful lot of
work with young people and you would
endorse therefore what the committee's
been saying yeah absolutely I think what
the government has done in terms of the
resettlement scheme and in terms of
leading the way in terms of humanitarian
aid to the region is really commendable
but can we do more absolutely we can and
it's really imperative that we do
particularly for these very vulnerable
we'll just pick apart I mean what the
government's been saying and you
mentioned it there a lot of work is
being done as as close to where the
refugees come from initially as possible
a lot of money being being put into
those camps that huge camps that have
been established in Turkey and Lebanon
and Jordan and other countries
absolutely and I think that is clearly a
very important part of the solution and
we do need more countries to follow the
lead of the UK and provide more aid to
that region but a humanitarian emergency
that's as complex as this theory of
crisis is needs a multi-faceted solution
and resettlement an additional help and
support for particularly vulnerable
children has to be a part of that well
we've got the we've got the number of
20,000 obviously not just children
20,000 at the UK says it will take by
2020 just in terms of pure numbers you
believe that's not enough I think it's
important that we do respond to this
quarter take an additional 3,000
unaccompanied children who are already
in Europe I think we do have the
capacity to do that the 20,000 is a
fantastic start but it is just a start
what are some of the individual stories
you've been hearing I mean people are
going to think children and some of them
are very young how do they actually get
that far without it seems obviously
without any parents but without any kind
of out old help well the organization
that I work for a refugee support
network provides intensive to support to
these children when they arrive in the
UK and our team see and hear their
stories of these children every day I
mean I could think of her saying who
spent ten days in the fridge compartment
of a lorry and now suffers with immense
headaches as a result of that Miriam who
was horribly abused by a people smuggler
and as we were hearing earlier
and even Safie who importantly and this
is a large numbers of children who don't
actually start the journey unaccompanied
but who in his case was forced into a
separate boat from his mother when
leaving Turkey and has never seen her
since despite desperate attempts to
trace her my goodness me and of course
what one imagines that some parents must
in whatever circumstances they find
themselves in let their children go let
them continue because for whatever
reasons they're not able to do so well
you think of Saffy's mother for example
the men and the women were put into
separate boats and as a boy he was put
with the men so she had to let him go it
was the only way for him to cross that
water and we don't know where she is
today so to me though like you know
3,000 the extra 3,000 children wouldn't
wouldn't even be enough anyway
well again like the 20,000 it would be a
really good start and it's a number that
I think we do have the capacity to
respond well and safely to to help these
young people get a really good start in
life here but ideally more I mean you
like see I mean they were talking about
overall millions of people here we are
talking about millions of people and we
have hundreds of people who have signed
up to become educational mentors to help
these children with their education when
they arrived in the UK and one of our
partner organizations has 10,000 people
signed up who are interested in
fostering a refugee child say yes we do
have the capacity to do more and but
today what we're calling for is for
these 3,000 to be researchers it just
tell us a bit more about what happens to
them in the UK because there are some
worries I've been reading some stories
and not just about some Syrians but you
know there are awful lot of
unaccompanied refugees who come into the
United Kingdom and some of them seem to
be disappearing off the radar and well
there's always been issues with
unaccompanied children going missing and
there are people who look to exploit and
abuse these children at all stages of
their journey including once in the UK
and what's really important is that
these children get placed in families
that they get back into school and that
they're helped to process some of the
trauma and the immense violence that
they've been exposed to but are there
enough I mean you talk about the
fostering are there enough families are
there enough ready and willing families
there to accommodate these ex
well like I said there were 10,000 at
least families who signed up to go
through the training process to become
foster parents it's important that
that's done thoroughly and rigorously
and but us and many other organizations
have been inundated over the last six
months with offers of support from the
public we have a waiting list of
volunteers now because there are so many
people who want to help these children
make a fresh start and both in terms of
family and in terms of Education okay
Katherine thanks very much a difficulty
as Katherine Gladwell there from the
refugee support network